Você sabia que o seu cérebro passa por
quatro grandes viradas ao longo da vida?
Pois é. E os momentos exatos podem te
surpreender. Um estudo publicado na
Nature Communications analisou mais de
4.000 exames cerebrais de pessoas de 0 a
90 anos e descobriu que o nosso cérebro
não envelhece de forma linear. Ele muda
de direção em quatro idades específicas,
aos 9, aos 32, aos 66 e aos 83 anos.
Olha só como isso funciona. Até os 9
anos, o cérebro está em poda intensa, se
especializando. Dos 9 aos 32, ele
integra redes e atinge o pico de
eficiência. Depois dos 32, começa uma
fase mais estável, mas com leve queda.
Aos 66, as redes ficam mais separadas,
mais modulares e a comunicação entre
áreas diferentes fica menos fluida. E
depois dos 83, o cérebro passa a
depender de menos regiões para manter
tudo funcionando. A boa notícia, estilo
de vida influencia muito essa
trajetória. Então, cuide o seu cérebro
em cada fase.